[Music] all right you're up citizens of the reject
Nation hello I'm your boy Aron here this here is
Greg ala that's right this Mr Greg ala over
here he's the man running the channel of the
whole godd dang thing I don't see how you do let's
go we are here to watch episode two of invincible
today that's right we are doing the whole dang
show and you're here to join us remember you
like this show you like us remember to ring that
Bell like this video subscribe do all the things
I'm doing good right I would have said you know
subscribe that you know I when our ration part
three is right right you just subscribe so you
know when reaction part 3 is up don't forget it
are you killing it yeah baby full length watch
alongs are going to be over on patreon for you
super sexy rejects that's where you go and sync
up with your own copy and you watch along with
us for the full unedited thing over there on
patreon that's where you get fulllength wasons
with Greg and John covering several shows over
there several exclusives a reaction highlights
and watch alongs included oh my God you did it
yeah baby all right are you ready to watch this
dang old show did the thing right better than I
expected hell yeah I watched the videos I've had
practice I can do it I can do the thing and I did
the thing I did the thing today damn it how'd I
do I did the
thing for some of you it probably seemed
like this day would never come for others
it came far too quickly reinal Val Johnson I
look out at this class and I see hope I see
a bright new world with a special place for
each and every one of you is Mark not at his
own graduation damn it Mark seriously going
to miss his own graduation is he he's just
running a little late he'll be here he promis
how could you miss Mr Winslow doing the speech
for your God bang High School Al seismic this
whole thing feels like a Spider-Man episode
we got Spider-Man homecoming here then you got
this Amazing Spider-Man 2 yeah okay yeah with
the with the tower okay I fell into a new realm
of understanding do you know what this obscene
phace is constructed from he asked expecting
some idiotic answer uh Granite stolen from
the Earth iron ripped from her loins so did he
actually fall into another realm isn't that most
buildings you can keep the ones made of
wood everything else we're taking back who's
weird oh no wo I made a few new friends
during my time Underground that's right
they were in the Montage at the end of
last SE season sometimes life hits you
with everything it's got like lava now
this part's like far from home cuz got
got the magma Men last time he Adam EES helped
to take on this guy yeah yeah [Music] yeah the
Earth three claims her stolen flesh too bad
she's out trying to get her diploma right now
he's got that chopped down just like
his dad that was great comic book
shot oh hell yeah Mark let's get it push it
to the limit even your greatest heroes are
useless against the power of dark that was a
solid uppercut punch nice I that definitely
was would have messed him up he seems like
he's a just a regular dude with tech would
have been better if you had stopped him before
he destroyed another one of America's greatest
treasures it's not destroyed I could
you know I could try pushing it back
out Abraham Lincoln once said whatever you
are be a good one did he really say that
it doesn't sound very lincy so all I missed
were the made up inspirational quotes cool
classic and I have is that silver were you making
out with Magma people I love how there was this
big buildup at the end of last season with the
return of Doc seismic and he just take it out
in the first few minutes of episode [Laughter]
two yeah the original the Invincible and it's
cracking more what is this shattering we
are leading to is like another spelling
behind it the shattering Dimensions oh yeah
peek to the other side or another side did I
tell you guys I'm volunteering for the Katy
Giles campaign that's your idea of a summer
vacation Giles is the real deal do you even know
your state comproller I don't even know what a
state comproller is I'm with you William never
even heard of it I'm uh going to go help finish
the Reconstruction up in Chicago that's amazing
Invincible should probably do that too speaking of
construct more beer she is like Christ Mark won't
even take me flying anymore boo his to graduation
and New Beginnings Mark damn he seems so goddamn
serious right now the guilt is Weighing on him he
has to do as much as possible to feel like he's a
hero if those seids ever take over Earth is next
we need to strike first Livingston what what
makes you think I know anything about martians
is that how you say it Martians [Laughter]
I sure they're bringing back both of these
plots in this episode astronaut interest
oh yep yep no one can blame you for being
a little uh [Music] jumping not yourself this
is the US Space Administration not therapy we
don't care about your mental health here SC about
the God dang job but effective immediately you're
taking a temporary leave till you can get your
head on straight oh wow you really looked out
here actually tried straightening
out his head I get [Laughter]
it it's crazy knowing how powerful
she actually is especially after the
the special we watched yeah you know how long
I've been Bing the city to clean up that mess 6
years
what problems is this going to create though yeah
I was thinking that right cuz I'm like At first
like this feels like a a Side Story you'd see
like a Spider-Man game I'm like okay but what
is what is going to be the ramifications
of her just making things willy-nilly like
this wow she went all out oh my God literally
made made a park in seconds will take humans
like years to do hey Mom no no everything's
fine great actually I was just thinking about
you and something wrong he's in the hospital
he's not dead I love him too much to kill him
off I love her verbally abusive father too
much to die I guess we're both still a bit
raw wow that window open just keeps that haunted
image behind them a reminder of their past right
across the street what about taking the time
to enjoy your last summer being a kid man I'm
not a kid anymore but that means making your
own choices you don't have to do everything
CA tells you yeah Mom I kind of do to prove
himself I understand why you think you have
to prove yourself but you don't you're a good
person no one thinks you're going to turn out
like your father then why would you even say
it yeah that's not what I meant Mark I need
you thank god oh no thank God get pulled away
from the thing that really should be tended
to man The Strain on the Rel relationship is
so tough somebody got me in the balls maybe
if you trained more and complained less
we could get back to saving lives hey man
Immortal Kate is that you who's Kate in there
with got a boo boo that could use some dupli
kisses dupli kisses we are not dating that's
inappropriate language for the workplace so
kiss your own boo boo boo boo huh what is
there something else going doing that you
godamn geriatric hypocrite this is none of
your business damn you and I were never a
thing Immortal and I are damn I mean look
at Immortal come on can you blame her man's
Abraham Lincoln we honor the guardian's Fallen
green doter Martian Man it's kind of crazy how
has he just been hiding this whole time right how
did he survive cuz it started off with something
small and just just kind of took over I wonder
how much of the original guy's Consciousness
is still in there Martian Man made Earth his
home but is it actually Martian Man or is it
a like a someone related I feel it's someone
related yeah cuz the yeah the actual one died
Midnight City been a virtual No Man's Land
since the midnight magician cursed it back
in 02 looks like Gotham cursed is that like a
metaphor no magic is real here what it's not
surprising pretty cool huh yeah it
was pretty dope please somebody help
me whoa God damn it's like a Gothic cyber Punk
World somebody help me yeah it's like the Batman
figure I am helping what is happening helping
make sure scum like you never heard another
innocent person again can't be the real
version of him dark queen was at my 12th
birthday party so I'm pretty sure he doesn't
kill people yeah is he like a shape shifter
killed by your father I was night boy his
assistant M Sid kick we don't use that term
it's degrading grading he's lost it you think you
hear them too huh the voices what oh he's lost it
huh oh he's talented he's good he knows what
he's do oh shoot ow my predecessor developed
this exoskeleton to help even the field
against those like you why didn't he use
it damn how does his speed keep up with
Mark welcome to the shadow verse this is
his land now I'm the hero here I'm saving the
world World from omn man's son a this is the
fear guess who they'll eat
first you would never like you said I'm omn man's
son a dude you have no idea what I'm capable of
use the fear against him it's funny he's using the
fear against him yeah guy who looks like Batman I
got to sign off something just came up anything
I can do I doubt it Debbie oh God she's going to
want Mark to take a break Mark almost missed his
high school graduation because of you I'm looking
out for him I'm easing him back into the job
it's not a job you can't just order him around
well at least he follows orders yeah unlike your
evil ex-husband I can't believe you'd even think
that after everything Mark went through and
what if you decide you can't trust him what
then they've given Debbie so much more agency
this time oh yeah I meant what I said about
looking out for Mark no dangerous stuff until
he's ready pres like omin man there she gets to
shine more sir the Mars file you requested how
is he alive Donald Debbie are you okay she was
just leaving oh there's a big secret Donald's
not aware is he a clone it's like a Coulson
situation hey guys are you and Dad fighting again
no nothing like that well then what I wonder
if it's a spiritual thing because dark blood
revealed he was an atheist be kind of ironic
Samantha her powers are so broken dude it's
insane she's God essentially what are you
doing in a burger March shirt it's called an
honest day's work took Mark's job Furniture
story you've been there for 20 years until you
people turn the Chicago corporate office into
a pile of rubble why didn't you tell me maybe
you should have asked instead of flying off to
God knows where doing God knows what you are
such a prick I can give you and Mom whatever
you want I've provided for this family longer
than you've been alive oh man your pride is
awful there 24 [Laughter] Karat I said change it
back man's Pride I know I would take advantage
of my da daughter's abilities she's offering
it to you on a golden apple I can't you just
produce money yeah just give just make bills
that's all you really need I'm taking you to
lunch ooh ooh there's this great thae place
down the street uh I had somewhere else in
mind oh my God just like his dad take her on
any trip ever take her to Europe my God you
brought me to Paris sort of is that a casino
Vegas ah nice yeah so it's just Las Vegas you
only get an hour for lunch and I can't fly you
the year up that fast without your skin ripping
off that's real how fast can you fly to Vegas
fast enough to turn into jelly Mark I need you
dinner tonight instead go save the world
Invincible you just got to Vegas make make
sure the voice in your ear isn't the only one
you listen to yeah listen to let them die have
fun with your girlfriend is she lever there damn
also I need to take you back to work first okay
you're late for what low tide something like
that turns out the atlantans are sore about
omn man murdering their King aquaris oh my God
atlantan law dictates that his sentence falls
to his next of kin you oh you want me to go to
war against an entire underwater civilization
according to atlantan custom the only way to
atone for the king's murder is to marry his
widow oh there you go I can't marry a fish
strictly symbolic all you have to do is go
through the ceremony maybe kiss the bride and
All Is Forgiven and everyone moves on and easy
oh Cil what a Croc of [__] conate couldn't
have told him first do the fish sleep with the
fish sorry kid I got another fire to put out
good luck down there I'll be listening yeah
you going to listen to that getting freaky with
a fish girl the lizard League call me back for
the lizard League they've hit a bio research lab
outside of Dallas the serpent Society it appears
that Supreme lizard has seized control in his
absence it's just a guy in a lizard suit that's
awesome and I'm not doing another me that me
better not be you Rudy I call me the shapes Smith
the shap sh there is a shape shifter this [Music]
hey wow cool Atlantis just like the Aquaman
movie you've got to saved the world and
just a kissy fish I can't do this and
definitely not here in in front of everyone
okay the this is kind of awkward but I have a
girlfriend isn't that why I'm here to be your new
king why would I need a king oh then we're not
getting married we abolish that barbaric custom
what do you think we are savages what's the plan
her to kill him thank you your your majesty
what's the plan her Mark's going to have to
kill the fish people cuz they want to kill him
so what's a new law trial by my combat release
the death dweller kill the fish this sucks he
has to pay the consequences for what his dad
did sins of the father what the it's a Pokemon
it's plushy oh no it's just a tip it's just a
tip it's like
SpongeBob it's like the the clam tongue with
the old lady you love interest uh if you're
not feeling ready let's sell this [__]
this place is adorable we'll take it when
are you taking offers Wednesday whoa slow
down I was just asking well don't bother
we're definitely not offering on this place
what's this guy's problem when you earn the
money you can decide where we live oh
no Debbie she's not your pet why don't
to take the rest of the day off I'll call
you later Debbie you need to get over your
[__] stop projecting Debbie yeah Debbie
everyone's gone through stuff not [Laughter]
special what the hell's going on down
there your file on atlantan law needs
some serious updating I'm pulling you
out back up own way sedu it Merc break
the chains and take it to land so you
can whip its ass [Laughter] [__] damn
he keeps going up against these Sonic
Blast thingies give him a Sonic clap
[Music] sound God damn mark one day you will live
up to your title how far away is that
get your lens cracked in the second
episode great good
backup oh no it's attacking the people now
oh no oo yikes damn prove you're not your
dad be a hero I can't leave those people to
die they tried to kill you all they wanted
was Justice for what my dad did you're
not your father prove it Mark disobey
those orders oh I feel this this is really
good going back aw you ain't your daddy
[Music]
boy I like these like flashes this Implement
show ooh [Music] come on Mark
hat that cinematic music very
much so smart let the weight pull
it down descend to the depths of the
Abyss I kick some dirt Over the Hole spit on it no
oh uh what the hell
inom Atlantis is calling it even
since you saved the Queen's life
the next time I give you an order you
listen even if it's the morally right
choice give it to the boys in R&D I want to report
in a week yes sir what sir when Debbie came to
speak with you she seemed distressed when she saw
me and she's a distressed person why bring Donald
back out of anyone must have some bigger role in
this season or something maybe he is in love with
him [Laughter] it's a secret lover you had your
job for years and losing it must feel awful I know
how hard you work to provide for Mom and me no one
is trying to take that away from you it feels like
it has no purpose now I'm trying to help like you
help Chicago the whole lot was unstable that's why
the city never built there oh oh no ramifications
your powers don't make you a hero they make you d
dangerous I have to go don't come back until you
figure that out out of the ear try to do something
good just backfires so Much Death oh she's going
to SP she's going to break it rip it off his
hinges yep you mother
yep would have thought they'
make Debbie such a compelling
ass character this season a clean this up
[Music] [Laughter] [Music] pet a hand over
heart oh they're both struggling like we don't
know anything about the shapes Smith I can tell
you I was born a baby human right here on
on the planet of Earth I don't believe you
oh it's um homeboy yeah yeah oh oh oh I got my
superpowers in a random industrial accident oh
God creepy as hell I swore to use my abilities
for good and to help people and to protect my
Planet no matter what the invasion we will
rise again any day now all H Supreme liard
all h g shot [Music] oh damn anyone is going
to turn this organization around it's going
to be king lizard any objections I guess not I
can't argue with that know anything about you
guys another breakout who who the hell are you
anyway think of me as an old friend given your
current predicament fine wait what not the
universe then they just wore me down cought
me when I finally had to sleep Dam okay
okay so there's a way to defeat him who
the hell are you oh that's what I said I'm
not your problem then whose problem are you
well not his but close enough hey you promised
you'd help me hey fascinating what's your play
guy's trying to get whatever
answers he can to defeat him
yeah okay all right was that was good I liked it
there's a lot of good stuff in there I think I
liked the first episode a little bit more but
I did enjoy the the journey here yeah wow wow
wow wow it's quite uh it's quite a lot of energy
you've brought [Laughter] here okay guys this was
the greatest episode ever uh no man I think
that you know there's a lot of interesting
stuff in here from the uh grieving of both um
Debbie and and Mark and how they go about that
and yeah Alice's relationship and finally seeing
the ramifications of that and like her trying to
help and really coming into her powers and yeah
I think there's just a lot of really interesting
things that they're uh they're planning forward
I the thing that that kind of caught my eye the
most though is like you know Debbie's individual
Arc and how we're really getting to hone in on
her more and that Coming to Terms or that coming
uh at the end meeting mark where he's at and what
I'm hoping for is like I know this season so far
is very much devoid of omn man but I would like
to not have omn man in this season or at least
for like 99% of it so that way like we see these
characters grow and like find some semblence
of healing and moving forward and right when
that happens omn man reenters the picture I
would agree with you but I think our videos
will get more views when omn man's here and to
me that's above storytelling it's view count
and if we want I what's the point of doing it if
we're not getting views you want the money I'd
rather have omn man I'd rather complain about
a poor story with omn man if that equates to
more views then less views and talk about good
storytelling you know when you say that I guess
it makes a lot of sense you know we just need omn
man here need omn he's the homelander of this show
I'm just saying have him shows nothing without
him I'm just saying well his presence uh lingers
throughout you know whether be in the consequences
of Mark with dealing with the people of Atlantis
or the fish fish beings of Atlantis yeah and I
like how it presents an opportunity for him to
provide restoration like a real moment of choice
where he could have just extracted Revenge really
demonstrating how he's not like his father MH I
thought was a beautiful moment I I was very I was
very much touched by that moment what they're
dealing with uh Debbie is something that I I'm
glad it's in the season and I expected that we
do something I wasn't expecting it to be such
a powerful AFF effect that would consistently
carry through as an arc for not just Debbie
but for Debbie and Mark's relationship and that is
the thing that I am personally the most gravitated
toward in terms of what the show sensibilities
are like they're keeping everything on a on a
much more personal grounded level like with Adam
Eve you know at the beginning there's such Joy
um being demonstrated to the public of look what
we can do as hero and look how we can change the
lives and then not thinking about certain things
of you know it's it's almost metaphorical in a
way of the foundation is not properly assembled
so trying to build a new structure on top of a
weak foundation will make everything crumble
and you could say that like mentally socially
psychologically for all of our characters who try
to do forms of escapism you know like Mark even
wanted to avoid a convers a tough conversation
with his mom by fighting something bad out there
in the world you know it it's I think they're
doing a lot of interesting things uh thematically
honestly like uh I'm like I'm really liking a
lot of this it's very different than the first
season where I am trying to grasp a s like the
post credit scenes have been helping to grasp
a sense of the direction of the Season MH because
the end of the last season would kind of have you
go all right everyone should just be gathering
and readying themselves for the return of omn man
or of the vulture M coming in to try to dominate
and that hasn't really been the focus no at all
at all and and I would like it to kind of go back
to that a tiny even if it's not even if it's not
including Omni man I would like some of the focus
to go back to that um Cliffhanger that we had of
last season that warning of the of the inevitable
you know and that that little inkling is is kind
of missing for me a little bit but we're only two
episodes in yeah I still think that that meeting
hasn't happened yet cuz I feel like that would be
like the top of his mind if you know that what me
the one with Allan the yeah the one Alan the the
alien yeah like hey your dad's coming he's going
to take over the planet cuz it hasn't really
even been mentioned at all you feel like that's
and especially with him dealing with the fact
that he does have this weight on his shoulders
of being compared to his father you think that'd
be something that's on the Forefront of his mind
the fact that his dad and his people are coming
so I think within the context of the story does
it wouldn't make sense for that to have happened
in us not to mention it and yeah cuz clearly that
at that point there was a time Jump well they're
bringing back they brought back a lot of things
here because you're dealing with not just the
grievance ramifications you're dealing with um
Cliffhangers of last season you know like Doc
seismic comes back and he's taking out pretty
fast yeah maybe that's just going to be a thing
every season because last EP he had like a whole
episode you know with Mount Rushmore with Adam Eve
and where he gets knocked in the volcano pit and
then at the end of um last season they showed he
was still alive with these lava beings whatever
and I was surprised by how after setting that up
at the end of last season that they kind of just
got resolved well maybe we're not done with it
maybe there's still more to do because like um
da Sinclair from the the last season we thought
he'd be like a one and done they started to use
him more yeah so that could be a silver situation
here well we also have um the armor mob guy um
arm mob guy with the with the who's like who's
like Luke Cage guy oh yeah yeah yeah who's like
a mobster now he like trick Mark into helping
him become the Kingpin yeah yeah that like we
still have that that we're probably going to bring
back because this was this was like bringing back
stuff like story lines that were not resolved
yeah we're still in the reestablishing stage of
this like we're still like the ramifications of
the immed the immediacy of last season before we
really said what's to come in the Forefront we had
the Martians and that whole thing thing with like
the uh parasite version of the alien encounter
when Mark was away on Mars and they were saying
like just takes one and then we saw that it took
over one now we're having to deal with that we're
going to see how that's going to factor in to
whatever malevolent threat that forms and and
with it being at the Guardians HQ being one of
the bigger threats now they're introducing the
lizard people which is kind of whatever to me I'm
like not that interested in it but we'll we'll see
imagine yeah I imagine that's going to be our
our immediate villain of the week so to speak
thing that happens within the next episode but I
don't know I feel like this show is really smart
about taking these comic book tropes and then
kind of elevating them in a way because like
they're they're really at this point in the show
really focus on focusing on humanizing uh all of
our characters and where we are so I feel like all
that stuff that they're setting up is going to be
thematically relevant to the characters once we
finally get into the full swing of what the basis
of this entire season's going to be yeah yeah I
mean I like the multiversal setup of this uh of
the guy Sterling Cape Brown is playing and I'm I'm
just very curious to see how it ultimately unfolds
to where any of this really M because because
there's a lot of threads that they're dealing
with there's a lot of characters and it's I feel
like it's at risk of feeling a little convoluted
it could yeah they got to be very careful with
how they kind of craft this season because we
we have threads that they're establishing that
have been started with in this season they have
stuff They're bringing back from last season yeah
and yeah how that all comes together I don't know
I will say that I'm curious about Sterling C
Brown's character so far but I'm not like on
the edge of my seat about it you know because
I feel like with omn man in season one with him
being the big threat there was this looming you
started off with this big mystery of like oh my
God why did ay man do this and then you just
have this character that's done this horrible
thing that everybody know that nobody knows but
we the audience know and it's just like this
it's like okay when's it going to break when when
things going to come to the there's more personal
entanglement exactly and there's a more personal
involvement with it as well but now we have this
guy who's like largely removed from our immediate
uh cast of characters and the only experience
we have with this universe's version of of Mark
having encountered this guy is what seeing him in
a machine and then it blowing up so I wonder how
much time you're going to give our main cast or at
least our main character uh to have some semblance
of connection with our new villain well it seems
like they're going to have something where it it
opens up the door for some type of crazy Universe
building event yeah where the stakes can be higher
than ever and I I feel like we'll get like not
just omn man but a different vulture might to
come in yeah I think my only question that could
be something of concern is that okay the omn
man threat is something that's of this universe
something that's personal and something that's
coming as far as what the last season established
with something like a Multiverse plot you're kind
of opening it up to something bigger than granted
less personal but something bigger than what we
established in the last season so I'm like how
are you guys going to go ultra big and then back
down to something uh small and personal and like
make that still um satisfying well the c k Brown
character is figuring out ways to get rid of omn
man and and and Invincible yeah you know like he
they're he's finding universes where they can be
defeated he's and so that makes it scarier for
Mark who's still like in in an amateur time like
I'm I'm loving the animation and I'm loving um
how C cesil is dealing is dealing with having
Mark and and seeing if he can truly still trust
this guy or and for Mark having to still work
around trying to form his own identity of no I can
make my my own choices and that doesn't mean I'm
going to make the wrong villainous choices like my
dad like it's almost as if he relies on C Cecil to
keep himself under control to not conform to the
dark side and I think he needs to have that level
of acknowledgement like it's still very character
driven and there there's a lot of things that I'm
I'm latching on to and I it's like you can't
first season you have eight episodes and we
like two episodes in and I I'm liking that it's
different I'm just sort of waiting to see how it
all ends before I'm like which one do I like more
but there is a Darkness that's looming throughout
all this that I'm really enjoying and I think the
animation is very striking and I'm loving um just
anytime with the intimate character development
like the the act it it breathes better than last
season it's like and I think it's earned that
level of breathing yeah it doesn't have to earn
you over like the the last season or the first
season did you know like okay we know we have our
audience so we can allow things to be a little bit
slower we still teasing things to come yeah yeah
yeah um be but right now we do have plots that
do feel like separated and I want them to feel
a little bit more connected because you got mark
on his own adventure but he's got nothing to do
with the Guardians right you know largely removed
from that whole plot and Cecil's running both and
it's like well I want to and before it was like is
that an intentional move from Cecil to keep Mark
away from the Guardians because before it was
omn man who was not under Cecil's rule did not
worked for him but was always teaming up with the
Guardians right right you know and then you got a
moral learn uh being the established leader again
and then watching whatever riffs happen there yeah
and he has mistrust of Mark so maybe that's proba
he's not part of the team yeah yeah exactly like
there's there's all these qualities you got Amber
doing whatever the hell Amber's doing you know
like you have this scene with the oh yeah you got
the the guy the I forget the name of him the son
of him too of like that's opening up this this guy
before that guy was just Batman in the last season
and then now his his number his number two is has
like special suit and his super fast and could do
like magical abilities I'm like how was this guy
the number two why was he a why was he a c um you
know sidekick some where he seems like so much
more powerful you know had all this Tech may I
don't maybe I can I can only imagine maybe um
this the original midnighter had this Tech but
like he reserved uh he used some because of like
ethics or something but now this guy is just like
screw it I'm just going to use all of the tools
I have at my disposal to keep Society safe in his
own way yeah there's just like a lot happening
right now yeah there's a lot of setup for sure
and I wonder if it's going to be able to balance
and pay off everything yeah I like the things that
they're setting up but again it's just like how
are they going to land all of it yeah yeah I am I
am on the verge of like is it going to become comp
because what what I care about I really care about
and there times I'm like oh this is cool this is
new this is fascinating and I'm always I'm always
enjoying it I'm always liking what's in front
of me um I guess I my mind's getting a little
caught up down the road of like is this going to
become too much yeah I'm really curious of where
uh where Alice Eve no Adam Eve is gonna go yeah
and uh yeah what's because she's essentially God
in this universe and she has these PE her parents
in her life that kind of make her question like
her not her purpose I guess but like if she is
doing actual good you know like her dad's like
that that insecure voice in her head yeah yeah
and yeah I wonder what's going to become of that
cuz she has the power to do pretty much anything
can live anywhere can she could probably stop all
of this crime by herself if she wanted to um
in a way I mean like she's like Dr Manhattan
I don't think she realizes her full po potential
yet oh yeah cuz she I don't think she's accessed
that that God State I think when she did the
Adam Eve like she accessed God state in the
Adam Eve special I don't think she was fully
aware yeah so that's probably something that's
going to come back in this season alrighty well
yeah so far I still give this episode at least an
eight out of 10 um and I'm excited to see where
we go I mean there's a reason they're releasing
them like this yeah and so I'm excited to see how
it all unfolds or would you rate it Aaron same I
would say like a 7.5 I think I like the the first
episode a little bit more but I think it's still
really good yeah yeah I'm enjoying it it's a good
show it's stays good or would you rank it out of
uh all the episodes that I've ever aired that's
hard how about you just rank how about you just
rank all the episodes right now right now top
10 list Mojo watch Mojo style I don't know man
what do you what do you rank it out of all the
episodes oh this is probably number uh six for
me six yeah yeah what's what's last last it's
the worst episode of the show um I'll probably
say uh I'm not the biggest fan of the dark seismic
episode yeah you didn't like it that much I mean I
liked it but it's my least favorite okay it's like
a it's like a classic villain of the week kind of
feel to that one it's yeah it's okay I feel it I
don't know I don't I don't have a a hard ranking
yet I think so I need to need to sit with it need
to let my my mental processes breathe a little bit
I'll come back I'll come back you next week and
tell you where everything ranks top to bottom top
all right guys well say hi to Aaron close us out
Aaron all right guys thanks for watching y'all
are the the best the sexiest rejects there are in
the land keep on watching we're going to keep on
doing this dang thing and uh yeah you're beautiful
how how you doing how's that that you do I don't
know I don't know we're doing it all right you
guys I'll see you guys next time bye go to some
[Music] accent